(applause)
- Welcome back.
So tonight we're
gonna talk about
the economics of being a woman.
By now, everyone
knows that women
only make 79 cents to the dollar
and that's actually why
I shop at Forever 21
so that I can be reminded
that I am forever 21 cents
less valuable than a man.
(audience groaning)
Obviously we need to
narrow the wage gap
and the thigh gap and
also the baby gap.
Nothing there fits me.
I feel fat.
Equal pay for equal
work is a no brainer.
So let's talk about
all the bullshit
women have to go through
just to make less than men.
Let's start at the beginning.
Getting ready for work.
It takes the average
woman three times longer
to get ready than
the average man.
And even longer if you're ugly.
(audience laughs)
That's extra time
a man can spend
reading, exercising,
or masturbating.
Whereas I have to multitask.
And let me tell you,
it's hard to get
through Angela's Ashes
while you're jackalackin'
on an elliptical.
(audience laughs)
I know some of you guys
are probably just saying,
"Well, why don't you just stop
putting shit on your face.
"We like you better
without makeup."
And to that, I'll say a
resounding, "Fuck you."
'Cause every time
I don't wear makeup
I get asked if I'm sick.
They're like, "Did someone
in your family die?"
I'm like, "No, I just woke up
feeling pretty and confident.
"Sorry, won't happen again."
Here's the sick thing.
Studies show that
women who wear makeup
actually earn more money,
which those women
are going to need
because makeup is
expensive as fuck.
Kurt, do you have any
idea how much this costs?
- Well, what, you
mean the nose job?
(laughing)
- I haven't yet.
It took over an hour
to do this tonight.
And yes, I do feel
better about myself
with my mask on.
But it's only
because without it,
I don't deserve love.
Look, it feels
like it sometimes.
I know damn well
that being a woman
is both awesome and a complete
pain in the ass at time.
But I wanted to hear it
from someone who understands
both sides of the
gender equation.
So I sat down with a friend,
comedian Riley Silverman,
who came out as a
woman six years ago.
Riley, I haven't
seen you for a while.
- It's been a long time.
- You really do have an
interesting perspective
because you lived as a man
and now you're
living as a woman.
Do you enjoy the extra
effort of being a woman?
- I think at first it
was really enjoyable
because it was part
of this ritual.
And you're like, "Oh
my God, I'm doing this.
"This is my everyday life."
Then after a month, you're like,
- Has there been a spike in
costs since transitioning.
- Everything is a
little bit more money.
Like everything costs more.
Like haircuts cost more,
clothing is always more
money for lower quality.
And then just even
having to buy makeup.
- Yeah.
- This adds up really fast.
- You're a pretty
big fashionista.
That's gotta be a huge
difference in your wardrobe.
- Yeah.
- Talk to me about the
change in cost there.
- Everyday, so I had to
have like a different skirt.
And that's like in my morning,
there's a lot of days where
I'm that exact stereotypical,
"I don't have anything to wear."
And I have a closet
full of clothes.
- Yes.
- Not only would it be
when I was living as a man
would I just wear a
pair of jeans every day.
It would be the same jeans.
Like you'd wear the same
jeans for like a month.
- Like how women wear bras.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Do you sleep in a bra?
- [Riley] No.
- [Nikki] Most women don't.
But I like, I need it.
It's like comforting because
my mom never hugged me.
(laughs)
It really is expensive
being a woman.
Products directed at women
like lotions,
razors, and shampoo,
consistently cost more
than similar products
directed at men.
Because I guess it's pricey
giving all our
deodorants tiny waists.
If it isn't shaped like a lady
then how will I
know it's for me?
That literally is what it.
They call this price
discrepancy the pink tax
because, I guess,
vaginas are pink.
I don't know, mine
isn't, whatever.
But that's something that
I don't think a lot of men
ever think about which
brings me to periods.
And sorry, I know,
I'm gonna talk
about periods for a second.
But I'm on mine, so I'll
fucking do what I want.
(audience laughs)
I'm not, I'm late.
No, a little while back
we did a segment
called Pay Your Tab Cab
where I picked up
guys from a strip club
and then gave them a
chance to win money
by answering
questions about women.
At one point in their ride,
I asked these men to demonstrate
their knowledge of periods.
Here's what happened?
(funky music)
Alright it is time for
the red zone challenge.
Are you ready?
- Excited
- What do we gotta do?
- I am like on my
period right now.
Here's 50 dollars.
I just need you
to go inside there
and just get me anything
that you think will help.
- Okay.
- Go, go, go.
- [Man In Hoodie] Hey.
- What'd you get?
- I got all the good stuff.
- Yeah.
- Stuffed turtle.
- Okay, why this?
- 'Cause when you're
cramping you need cuddles.
You know, you're sad.
- And pink because?
- 'Cause girl.
(laughs)
- Okay, well, we
got you right here.
We got you covered.
I got you the pads.
- What are those?
Those look like diapers.
- They only had a 34 pack
and I don't know
how many you use.
- You got me pads?
Do you think I'm Mormon?
What the hell is this?
- I don't know how they work.
- I'll just like,
I'll roll these up
and stick 'em up
like they're tampons.
- Good.
- [Nikki] Cool.
- [Blonde Man] That's good.
- These are the
nessentials, you ready?
- Okay.
- Chocolate with almonds.
- Okay, okay, we're talking.
- I even got three
chocolate bars.
Two for you and one for me.
- Oh my God, that's
so sweet of you.
- That way I don't got
to ask for none of yours.
And you don't got to
ask for none of mine.
- It's nice that you think
about yourself in these times.
Anything else?
- I got you a Lean Cuisine.
- I'm on my period
not suicide watch.
- Condolence card.
- Our thoughts are with you.
This is a condolence card
because you're going
through your period.
- Yes.
I thought you'd need it.
- You're not wrong.
- For somebody who ain't
never had a period before
I think I did okay.
- You really did,
you really did.
- Yeah.
- I hope you get one.
- I hope I don't because it's
a lot of shit for a period.
- Isn't it?
(audience cheers)
The struggle is real.
The minutes and dollars it takes
to look normal as
a woman add up.
So the next time I hear an actor
from some movie
complaining about,
"Oh, I had to sit
in a makeup chair
"for three hours to
look like a monster."
Try and remember that
we do that every day
so people don't think
we look like monsters.
We'll be right back.
(audience cheers)